alors monsieur du snav vous êtes très
par bardot je vous demande si vous êtes
très vous êtes sourd casimir je ne suis
pas sourd seulement on sait pas bien
toute la journée tu pourrais au moins de
saluer bon voilà bonjour monsieur du
snap d'abord je vois pas pourquoi tu me
pose cette question mais enfin nous
avions rendez vous aujourd'hui pour
répéter notre texte
ah mais c'est vrai tu as raison casimiro
qu'elle aura quelle abomination en
double il apprendre mon texte n'ont
enfin pas quoi penser vous vous êtes
vraiment un mauvais élève je sais je
sais je suis couvert de au bon moment ça
va découvrez-vous et apprenez votre
texte bon moi je vais répéter mes
exercices de diction un petit pot de
beurre quand un des petits pots de
beurre ratu les chaussettes de
l'archiduchesse font pas recette
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
france soir on reçoit à vous qui savez
tous pouvaient m'aider j'ai besoin de
vous mais certainement aussi du snob
mais mais vous semblez tout affolé
calmez vous tenez asseyez vous sur la
chaise merci beaucoup alors monsieur les
snobs que puis-je faire pour vous et
bien voilà avec casimir nous avons
décidé de faire une représentation
théâtrale pour tous nos amis de l'île
aux enfants et bravo monsieur des snobs
mais voilà une excellente idée
salma le drame c'est que je ne me paraît
pas à retenir mon texte hi hi lire et le
relire je ne retiens rien même si le
seul ce n'est pas lire qu'il faut c'est
qu'il faut dire son texte à haute voix
et faites le et vous retenir beaucoup
mieux à bout vous croyez une j'en suis
sûr tenez donnez moi votre texte - la
voyons au les plaideurs de racine oui
bravo c'est très intéressant simple vous
connaissez un signe les enfants c'est un
auteur de théâtre qui a vécu à la fin du
xviie et au début du xviiie siècle il
écrit beaucoup de tragédies et une seule
comédie justement les plaideurs aussi du
snob était en train d'apprendre the sun
je sais pas quel est le rôle que vous
apprenez le rôle de petit jean petitjean
s'amusera très bien car ça va être très
simple je vais vous dire le texte oui
mais vous le répétez après moi d'accord
à lorient petit jean louis la fois sur
l'infini y est un fou qui se fiera will
elle qui rit vendredi dimanche pleurera
vous
sur l'avenir ma foi non non non non je
n'ai pas fait attention c c'est le
contraire 50 secondes sur l'avenir maaf
loi non que je vous faites exprès je
vais je vous dis que senna fois sur
l'avenir enfin je n'arriverai jamais
c'est pas possible même si du snav non
je vous en prie ne laissez pas tomber
avant même d'avoir commencé en fait il
faut s'accrocher dans la vie je
travaillais faut persévérer
allez-y à les avez raison vous avez
raison je crois toujours que grâce à des
dons naturels je dois arriver à tout
savoir tout connaître sans jamais
travailler c'est faux je le sais bien
aller et laissant tomber le nom à notre
texte ne nous
écoute toujours au même endroit ma foi
sur l'oeuf ah oui oui à les écouter
france je crois qu'un verre de limonade
me fera le plus grand bien je n'en
reviens tout
ma chère amie entourage avoir un verre
de limonade j'étais justement en train
de m'en servir à tenais merci beaucoup
je n'ai pas de monnaie sur moi mais je
vous en prie je mettrais station va tron
madame merci beaucoup voilà j'ai repris
alors allons-y josé coup tu
n'as fois sur l'avenir
très bien bravo
si les snobs o messi 19 heures au zénith
à voir de toutes les couleurs qui
voulait être dessus de notre tête tout
ça au coach je vous en prie monsieur de
jetons mais vous pensez à mille autres
choses pensez à votre texte vous n'y
arriverai jamais comme ça ne pensez qu'à
votre texte allez un bon
l'avenir sur ma foi et l'avenir sur la
toile à lacets chez n'importe quoi
pourquoi pas non du coup c'est pas ma
faute bonsoir j'ai les mots qui ce qui
se brouille qui se mélangent dans ma
tête j'ai l'impression qu'ils le font
exprès pour me faire tromper
le seul islam je ne vois qu'une seule
chose vous n'avez pas de mémoire c'est
au fond c'est épouvantable
fulbert on se le dise non pas deux mais
moins cet affreux
la mémoire ça peut s'acquérir ça fait
seulement il faut travailler voilà
cultiver je vais pas me laisser dire que
ce n'est pas de mes gilets jaunes comme
bravo allez allez
9 fois son avenir bien phu qui se firent
à
l'aide d'un seul train d'arriver voyez
vous pouvez y arriver
et combien de verres vous reste-t-il 1
issus du soir
[Musique]